E
HAVE BEEN MISLED AS TO WHAT THE
FACTS WERE.
>> Greg: I THINK THE IMPORTANT
TH SAID WAS, AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I SAID YESTERDAY.
WE ONLY GET THE STORY AFTER IT
HAPPENS AND WE SHOULD ADDRESS
EVERY VARIABLE, EVERY STEP THAT
GETS TO THAT CRIME.
WHETHER IT'S MENTAL ILLNESS,
SCHOOLS, FAMILY, RED FLAGS.
HE SAID IT'S A NEW THING IN THE
DECADE AND A HALF, THAT KIND OF
POINTS YOU IN THE DIRECTION OF
WHERE THE ANSWERS ARE.
WHY ARE THESE THINGS HAPPENING
MORE AND MORE THIS KIND OF
SOCIETY?
IS IT SOMETHING THAT HAS TO DO
WITH NOT SIMPLY THE AVAILABILITY
OF GUNS BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE.
SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT'S A DECLINE IN EDUCATION,
BREAKDOWN OF THE FAMILY.
THESE ARE A LOT OF THINGS WE
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT BECAUSE
WE HAVE AVOIDED THESE PROBLEMS
FOR SO LONG.
FOR 50 YEARS.
YOU CAN SAY THE GOVERNORS LIVID.
YOU CAN SAY THE POLICE WERE
INCOMPETENT OR THEY WERE AFRAID
OR ADHERING TO A DOCTRINE THAT
PREVENTED IMPROVISING.
THAT'S NOT MY PLACE.
THAT'S HIS PLACE.
THAT'S THE PLACE FOR THE
INVESTIGATORS TO LET THEM
INVESTIGATE FULLY TO TELL THE
STORY.
YOU NEED THE SCRUTINY.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A NEXT TIME
AND THE INFORMATION YOU GLEAN
FROM THIS TIME WILL HELP YOU IN
THE NEXT TIME.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
IT ISN'T MONDAY WARNING
QUARTERBACK FOR INVESTIGATORS,
LAW ENFORCEMENT, SURVIVORS TO
QUESTION IT.
AS THE MEDIA WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL BECAUSE WE MONDAY
MORNING QUARTERBACK FIVE DAYS A
WEEK.
IT'S AMAZING TO ME HOW WE ALL
BECOME EXPERTS ON EVERY -- IT'S
AMAZING.
I DIDN'T GO TO SCHOOL FOR ANY OF
THIS BUT SOMEHOW I CAN HAVE AN
OPINION.
BE HUMBLE.
LET THEM DO THE JOB.
LET THEM TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
POLICE DID OR DIDN'T DO AND LET
THE STORY GROW.
LET THE FACTS PILE UP.
>> Judge Jeanine: JOEY, THE
GOVERNOR WAS TALKING ABOUT AND
THE STATE HEIGHT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY CAME
OUT AND SAID THAT THE SCHOOL
DIRECTOR.
HIS NAME WAS MacGRAW, MADE A
MISTAKE.
IN THAT INSTEAD OF DEALING WITH
THIS GUY, RAMOS, AS AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER, THEY DEALT WITH HIM AS
A BARRICADED SHOOTER.
YOU'VE GOT ADHERENCE TO THE
CHAIN OF COMMAND.
YOU ARE A MILITARY GUY.
YOU'VE GOT PARENTS OUTSIDE
SCREAMING, YELLING, BEING
HANDCUFFED ACCORDING TO SOME.
BEING THROWN TO THE GROUND
ACCORDING TO OTHERS, LISTENING
TO SHOTS PERIODICALLY THROUGH
THIS.
DO YOU ALWAYS LISTEN TO CHAIN OF
COMMAND IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOUR GUT IS TELLING YOU THAT
THERE IS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
I'M HEARING AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
>> I AM A MILITARY GUY, NOT A
POLICE GUY.
THAT'S TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> Judge Jeanine: CHAIN OF
COMMAND'S CHAIN OF COMMAND.
>> FAIR.
MY REASON FOR POINTING THAT OUT
IS TO NOT CREDIBILITY I DON'T
HAVE ON THE TOPIC.
MONDAY MORNING QUARTERBACK OR
VOICING EXPECTATIONS.
THAT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S HIS JOB TO SAY THESE ARE
THE PROTOCOLS WE HAVE.
ACTIVE SHOOTER, YOU RUN TO THE
GUN, YOU GO TO THE GUN AND YOU
TAKE IT OUT.
A HOSTAGE SITUATION IS VERY
DIFFERENT.
I TEXTED PETE HEGSETH 48 HOURS
AGO AND SAID THIS LOOKS A LOT
LIKE -- THEY HANDLED IT LIKE A
HOSTAGE SITUATION.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THAT IS.
I WAS NOT IN THAT ROOM.
I WAS NOT IN THE HALLWAY.
I WAS NOT IN THE SCHOOL.
I CAN'T TELL YOU.
>> Judge Jeanine: WE ALL KNOW
THAT BUT WHAT WE KNOW NOW IS
CHILDREN ARE CALLING.
SHOTS ARE RINGING.
WHAT WE KNOW NOW TODAY.
WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS THAT 11:35
OFFICERS GO IN.
THEY ARE BEING SHOT AT.
AT 11:35.
AT 12:16 THERE IS A 911 CALL,
SHANNON.
ONE OF THE KIDS SAYS EIGHT OR
NINE OF US ARE ALIVE.
AT 12:21, THERE ARE THREE SHOTS
RINGING OUT.
THEY HAVE GOT AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
WHY DOES IT GO FROM 12:21 TO
12:50 FOR THEM TO FIGURE OUT
THAT THERE IS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
>> I WOULD LIKE THAT ANSWER TOO.
>> Shannon: WERE THE 911 CALLS
BEING RELAYED TO THE COMMANDER
ON THE SCENE?
IF YOU ARE TREATING IT AS A
BARRICADE SITUATION WHERE MAYBE
THERE ARE NO CHILDREN ALIVE IN
THAT ROOM AND IT'S JUST THE
SHOOTER COMING OR GOING TO
HANDLE IT DIFFERENTLY.
WE YOU HAVE REPEATED CALLS.
I FEEL LIKE THEY ARE GOING TO
RELEASE THOSE 911 CALLS AND IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY HARD TO
LISTEN TO THEM.
CHILDREN ARE BEGGING.
THEY ARE IN THERE FOR 30, 40, 5.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT WAS
LIKE.
WE ARE FURIOUS AND HEARTBROKEN
AND WE ALWAYS WANT QUICK ANSWERS
BECAUSE AS HUMAN BEINGS WANT TO
TRY TO MAKE SENSE OF THIS AND WE
CANNOT MAKE SENSE OF THIS.
IT DOES TAKE TIME TO GET THERE
AND GREG, AS YOU TOUCHED ON, WE
CANNOT PRETEND LIKE OUR SOCIETY
HAS NOT BROKEN DOWN AT THE
FAMILY LEVEL, COMMUNITY LEVEL,
CHURCH LEVEL.
WE HAVE DONE THINGS THAT HAVE
ACTIVELY RIPPED THOSE
INSTITUTIONS APART AND THEN
WONDER WHY WHEN THERE'S A YOUNG
MAN WHO IS BULLIED, MADE FUN OF,
HIS FAMILY IS ESTRANGED AND A
COMPLETE MESS THAT HE DEVOLVES
FURTHER AND FURTHER INTO THESE
ONLINE COMMUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE
FIND TOXIC RELATIONSHIPS AND
IDEOLOGIES.
THEY WANT A SENSE OF SELF-ESTEEM
AND SENSE OF BEING IN ALL OF
THOSE PLACES THEY COULD'VE FOUND
IT ARE BEING RIPPED AWAY.
WE CANNOT ACT LIKE NOT EXAMINING
THAT AND PASSING A BUNCH OF LAWS
ARE GOING TO MAKE THESE YOUNG
MEN BETTER.
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER HAD A
TERRIFIC PIECE HE WROTE AFTER
THE SANDY HOOK SHOOTING.
I WISH HE WAS STILL WITH US.
IT TALKS ABOUT A CULTURE OF
VIOLENCE AND HOW WE HAVE BROKEN
THINGS DOWN AND WE CANNOT
PRETEND THOSE THINGS DON'T
MATTER.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN TO THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
DIRECTOR AND WHAT HE SAID
EARLIER.
I'LL GET BACK TO YOU.
SPEAK WITH THE BENEFIT OF
HINDSIGHT, WHERE I AM SITTING
NOW OF COURSE IT WASN'T THE
RIGHT DECISION.
IT WAS THE WRONG DECISION,
PERIOD.
NO EXCUSE FOR IT.
I WASN'T THERE BUT I'M TELLING
YOU FROM WHAT WE KNOW, WE
BELIEVE THERE SHOULD'VE BEEN AN
ENTRY AS SOON AS YOU CAN.
>> THE CHIEF OF POLICE, HE WAS
CONVINCED.
I WANT TO GO BACK AND SAY HE WAS
CONVINCED AT THE TIME THAT THERE
WAS NO MORE THREAT TO THE
CHILDREN AND THE SUBJECT WAS
BARRICADED AND THEY HAD TIME TO
ORGANIZE WITH THE PROPER
EQUIPMENT.
>> TEXAS EMBRACES AND TEACHES
THE ACTIVE SHOOTER DOCTRINE AS
LONG AS THERE'S KIDS, AS LONG AS
SOMEONE IS FIRING, YOU GO TO THE
GUN.
FIND HIM AND NEUTRALIZE HIM.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE ACTIVE
SHOOTER DOCTRINE, HAROLD.
>> I WANT TO GIVE
GOVERNOR ABBOTT A LOT OF CREDIT.
WE ARE IN A DIFFERENT PARTY BUT
FOR HIM TO STAND FOR THE PRESS
AND ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS, REAL
LEADERSHIP, ACCOUNTABLE, SHARES
CREDIT WITH THINGS GO RIGHT AND
WHEN THINGS GO WRONG YOU'RE
ACCOUNTABLE AND I GIVE THEM
CREDIT FOR THAT.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT TWO
RESPONSES.
THE RESPONSE OF THE OFFICERS ON
THE GROUND WHICH OBVIOUSLY WAS A
DEVASTATING DISASTER.
A FATAL DISASTER.
AND THEN WHAT I THINK HE WAS
EQUALLY LIVID AT AS I HEARD IN
HIS VOICE IN HIS WORDS, THAT HE
WAS LIED TO ABOUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AFTERWARDS.
I UNDERSTAND AND WE CAN ALL
EXCEPT IN A PAINFUL WAY HOW
MISTAKES CAN BE MADE.
I LISTEN TO MR. MacGRAW SAYING
THAT THE OFFICER COMMANDER
FOOLISHLY, WRONGLY THOUGHT THAT
IT WAS A BARRICADE SITUATION BUT
ONCE YOU LEAVE THERE, ONE THING
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND IS
CONSISTENT WITH, IF YOU LIED
YOUR SUPERIOR, YOU MISLEAD YOUR
SUPERIORS.
EVERYONE WHO LIED TO THE
GOVERNOR AND POLICE CHIEF IN THE
MIRROR SHOULD BE FIRED
IMMEDIATELY.
NUMBER TWO, THIS IS A PUBLIC
SAFETY CONVERSATION THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN HERE WE ALWAYS TRY TO SAY
THAT WE WANT TO TAKE POLITICS
OUT OF THINGS, YOU CAN'T TAKE
POLITICS OUT OF THINGS.
WE ARE POLITICAL BEINGS AND WE
HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT THERE IS A
MODICUM OF THAT IN THE
CONVERSATION.
WE'VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT SCHOOLS
AND WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN.
THERE'S EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND FOUR SECURITY RESOURCE
OFFICERS.
THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE.
THE QUESTION AROUND MINERS AND
MENTAL ILLNESS AND WHETHER OR
NOT -- WE HAVE HAD MENTAL
ILLNESS IN OUR SOCIETY FOREVER.
WE HAVE HAD EVIL SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF MANKIND.
AUSTRALIA HAS EVIL BUT THEY
HAVEN'T HAD A MASS SHOOTING
SINCE 1996.
DO WE LOOK AT WHAT OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE DOING?
WE HAVE TO PUT IT ALL ON THE
TABLE BUT I WAS MOST IMPRESSED
WITH THE PRESS CONFERENCE
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
MAYOR, THIS HAS BEEN TWO OR
THREE DAYS, TWO DAYS.
THEY HAVE LET FACTS GUIDE THIS
CONVERSATION AND THE RESPONSE ON
THE SCENE, DISASTER, FATAL
DISASTER.
WHAT I'VE EQUALLY AND IF NOT IN
A WEIRD WAY MORE DISTURBED BY,
IT SEEMS LIKE LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEN LIED TO THE GOVERNOR AND
LIED TO THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY LEADER AND LYING
TO THE MAYOR.
THAT IS NOT ONLY FIRABLE, I HAVE
ANOTHER PLACE IN MIND THAT THOSE
PEOPLE ARE RESERVED FOR RESERVED
FOR.
TO >> Judge Jeanine: WITH
RESPECT TO THE HARDENING OF THE
SCHOOLS, WE KNOW THAT THE TEACHR
WHO OPENED THE DOOR AT 11:27.
AT 11:28 THERE IS A CRASH AND
SHE RUNS INTO MAKE A 911 CALL AT
11:30.
AND THEN SHE DOESN'T GO BACK AND
CLOSE THE DOOR.
AND THEN WHAT IS CRAZY ABOUT IT,
JOEY, HE THEN JUMPS THE FENCE
WITH A LONG GUN.
THEY SAY AN AR-15.
AND A BAG OF AMMO AND HE SHOOTS
AT THE SCHOOL BEFORE HE EVEN
GETS INTO THE SCHOOL.
THEY CALL THE SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER.
HE DRIVES VIA PEER MAYBE HE
DIDN'T SEE THE GUY BUT THEN
DOESN'T GO BACK TO THE SCHOOL.
>> Joey: THE LAST THING I
HEARD IN MY BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
EVEN BEING ON LIVE TV TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS WHATEVER WE SAY
AND TALK ABOUT RIGHT NOW,
SOMETHING'S GOING TO CHANGE
TOMORROW.
THAT'S WHAT'S BOTHERING ME SO
MUCH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT
THE SEVERITY OF THIS PROBABLY
WITH THEIR INITIAL INSTINCT
TRYING TO COVER THEIR OWN TAIL.
IT CHANGES THE NARRATIVE OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THEIR OWN MIND TO
THE POINT THEY BELIEVE IT AND
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM.
THIS RESOURCE OFFICER.
WHEN I WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL -- HE
MAY BE A FANTASTIC POLICE
OFFICER NOW BUT WE CALLED HIM
BARNEY FIFE.
THAT WAS THE PRESENCE THAT HE
HAD.
BECAUSE YOU PUT HIM SOMEWHERE
THAT YOU DON'T THINK MANNERS
BECAUSE YOU'RE OUT THERE
CATCHING DRUG DEALERS AND
MURDERERS ON THE STREETS AND THE
SCHOOLS ARE A SAFE PLACE.
THAT HAS CHANGED.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE NEED ANYMORE.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER THERE.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE FOUR
OFFICERS FOR DISTRICT OF EIGHT
SCHOOLS.
I DO KNOW THAT THEY USUALLY PUT
PRIORITY ON HIGH SCHOOLS RATHER
THAN ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS HAVE TO
CHANGE BUT THEY ARE THINGS THAT
SHOULD'VE CHANGED YEARS AGO.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A RURAL
AREA.
TEXAS STATE SENATOR THAT WAS ON
"FOX AND FRIENDS" THIS MORNING
TALKING ABOUT FRUSTRATION.
IT MIGHT'VE BEEN THE MAYOR.
I BELIEVE IT WAS THE MAYOR,
FRUSTRATION.
IF THEY NEED CERTAIN TYPES OF
RESOURCES, GUIDANCE COUNSELORS,
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS FOR
STUDENTS, THEY HAVE TO GO TO
SAN ANTONIO.
THEY HAVE TO GO THE PLACES THAT
ARE 20, 30, 50 MILES AWAY.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT HAVE
TO BE ADDRESSED AND BACK TO THE
SECURITY OF THE SCHOOL, FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE WAS AN
AWARDS DAY AND THAT'S WHY
SECURITY WAS LAX AS FAR AS
ENTERING AND EXITING.
>> EARLIER IN THE MORNING.
>> Joey: IF THAT IS THE CASE,
COMMON SENSE SAYS YOU BRING IN
MORE OFFICERS.
MORE PHYSICAL PERSONS.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE CRAZY
PART ABOUT IT IS THAT APPARENTLY
TWO MONTHS BEFORE, THEY HAD
ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAINING AND THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
FOR THE ELEMENTARY, THE MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL.
>> Shannon: THERE WAS A
POSTING ON FACEBOOK AT SOME
POINT THAT THE UVALDE S.W.A.T.
TEAM HAD GONE AROUND TO LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS AND
DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE TO BE AFRAID.
WE ARE COMING SO WE CAN LEARN
THE LAYOUTS OF THESE PLACES SO
IF SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS
WE ARE READY TO GO.
THE NUMBER ONE QUESTION I HAVE,
WHY THE UVALDE S.W.A.T. TEAM WAS
NOT THERE.
ALL THE ACCOUNTS WE'VE HEARD,
THEY WERE NOT A FACTOR.
IF THEY WERE IN THAT COMMUNITY,
THEY HAD THE BALLISTICS
PROTECTION EQUIPMENT AND
EVERYTHING THEY NEEDED AND THEY
HAD DONE DRILLS AND HAD CHECKED
OUT THESE SCHOOL SPECIFICALLY
FOR THIS, THAT IS MY NUMBER ONE
QUESTION.
I HOPE THE GOVERNOR WILL GET THE
ANSWER.
WHY WASN'T IT THE S.W.A.T. TEAM?
WHY WAS IT A BORDER PATROL TEAM
THAT SHOWED UP?
THEY WERE HELD OFF AMANDA FORCED
THEIR WAY IN.
>> Judge Jeanine: MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WHEN ONE OF THE
SCHOOL TEACHERS CALLED HER
HUSBAND.
WASN'T HE A BORDER GUY?
HE BORROWED A RIFLE FROM A
BARBERSHOP AND WENT IN HIMSELF.
>> GOT HIS KIDS OUT.
WHY DID HE GET IN?
WE HAVE 21 PEOPLE AS I THINK,
WE'VE GOT 19 COPS IN THE
HALLWAY.
FROM 12:03 TO 12:50.
19 COPS.
KIDS ARE BLEEDING OUT ALL THAT
IS HAPPENING.
>> Greg: I ADMIT WHEN I HEAR
ABOUT HER TERRIBLE TRAGEDY.
FOR ME, THE LONGEST TIME IT WAS
FLIGHT 93.
YOU ALWAYS RUN THROUGH YOUR
HEAD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS, JOEY,
BECAUSE YOU'RE IN THE MILITARY
NEW BED IN THESE SITUATIONS.
BUT IN MY HEAD I'M ASKING, WHAT
WHAT I DO?
WHAT WOULD I DO AT THE PULSE
NIGHTCLUB IF I WAS THERE?
YOU WOULD THINK THAT YOU WOULD
REACT ONE WAY BUT YOU DON'T
KNOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO DO A -- I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK I WOULD DO AMAZING
THINGS, CHARGE AND THERE AND
KILL THE KILLER AND RESCUE
PEOPLE BUT YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS TO YOUR BRAIN, EVEN IF
YOU'RE BEING TRAINED FOR THIS.
WE ARE COMING DOWN PRETTY HARD
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT MAYBE THEY
DESERVE IT BUT WE ARE NOT THE
EXPERTS HERE.
SO I WOULD JUST URGE PEOPLE.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW.
HOW DO YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITUATION AND BARRICADING
SITUATION, AS WE ARE CRITICIZING
THAT.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Shannon: THE 911 CALLS ARE
STILL COMING IN, PEOPLE THAT YOU
KNOW ARE ALIVE.
>> I HEAR YOU AND I DON'T LIKE
THEM MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACKING.
THIS IS WHAT THIS GUYS TRYING TO
DO.
NO ONE SHOWS UP ON THE GUTFELD
SHOW AND SAYS I WANT TO HOST.
I THINK I CAN DO IT.
THERE ARE THREE GUYS WHO TRY TO
DO IT AS WELL AS YOU.
THERE'S ONE ON THE WEST COAST.
THEY DON'T.
YOU DO IT WELL.
WE TALKED ABOUT A CASE FOR A GUY
GOT OUT OF JAIL BECAUSE HE
ESCAPED APPARENTLY WITH PRISON
GUARD AND HE CHECKED OUT BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T MAKE HIM SIGN A NOTE
ABOUT WHERE THEY WERE GOING.
YOU HAVE ONE FAILURE AND A
CASCADING EFFECT.
GREG, I AGREE BUT IF IT'S MY
KIDS.
WE CAN TALK BIG.
THE ONLY GUY WHO'S ACTIVE BIG IS
JOEY HERE BUT IF I SAW SOMEONE
ON A SUBWAY.
LIKE IN PHILADELPHIA.
I WOULD THROW MYSELF IN FRONT OF
THEM.
IF MY KIDS ARE PUT IN HARM OR
PUT IN DANGER, YOU COULD PUT A
BULLET IN MY HEAD.
TWO GUNS, THREE GUNS, AND AR-15.
I DON'T CARE WHAT IT IS.
I AM GOING IN.
>> Judge Jeanine: I AM GOING
IN.
COPS ARE TRAINED TO GO IN.
>> Greg: I UNDERSTAND THAT.
I AM NOT TRAINED AS AN EXPERT TO
RIP THEM ALIVE ON THE NEWS.
>> Judge Jeanine: WE ARE NOT
RIPPING THEM ALIVE.
WE ARE TALKING.
>> Joey: MULTIPLE TYPES OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WERE
INVOLVED.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE YOU HAVE
TO IDENTIFY THE COMMANDER AND
LET THEM HAVE THE AUTHORITY.
OTHERWISE YOU HAVE PEOPLE.
THAT MUCH OF IT I UNDERSTAND.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT MADE THEM
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS SAFER FOR
THE KIDS IN THE ROOM TO STAY
OUTSIDE THE DOOR.
I 100% BELIEVE THEY ACTED ON
THAT NOTION.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT ABOUT
WHEN THE COP SAID IF YOU NEED
HELP, YELL HELP.
ONE OF THE KIDS SAID, WHEN THAT
KID YELLED HELP, THAT KID GOT
SHOT.
>> Shannon: I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
I WONDERED IF IT WAS THE KILLER
HIMSELF PRETENDING TO BE THE
COP.
THERE IS SO MUCH WE DON'T KNOW.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE BABIES WHO
SURVIVED THIS ARE THE ONES
HAVING TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION.
>> Judge Jeanine: DO WE KNOW
HOW MANY KIDS GOT OUT?
>> Shannon: I DON'T THICKLY
DO.
THE SCHOOL HAD MORE THAN 600
KIDS.
THEY WERE BREAKING OUT WINDOWS
AND TAKING KIDS OUT FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE SCHOOL.
I AM WITH YOU, GREG.
MY LATE FATHER WAS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO DO IS
CAST ASPERSIONS.
I AM JUST ASKING QUESTIONS.
THAT'S IT FOR NOW.
MY FATHER WOULD'VE ASKED THE
SAME QUESTIONS.
>> Harold: GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
I'M A HUGE SUPPORTER OF POLICE
OFFICERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE SECOND PART OF THIS, I
UNDERSTAND YOU CAN HAVE THE
WRONG REACTION WITH THE RIGHT
INTENTIONS IN ANY GIVEN
SITUATION.
BUT ONCE THE SITUATION IS OVER
AND YOU LIVE ABOUT IT.
THAT TO ME IS WHAT MAKES SOME OF
THIS UNFORGIVABLE.
>> Joey: A MISTAKE DOES NOT
NEGATE INTEGRITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: TEXAS
OFFICIALS GETTING EMOTIONAL
DURING THE PRESS CONFERENCE
EARLIER.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THANKS A LOT.
FORGET HOW I'M DOING.
WHAT ABOUT THE PARENTS OF THOSE
CHILDREN.
FORGET ABOUT ME.
WE TAKE AN OATH TO UPHOLD THE
LAW AND PROTECT PEOPLE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I USED TO
PROSECUTE CHILD-ABUSE HOMICIDES
AND I NEVER SAW COPS GET MORE
EMOTIONAL THAN THEY WOULD WITH
THESE CHILD-ABUSE HOMICIDES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THIS
GOVERNOR TALKED ABOUT.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON MENTAL HEALTH.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH, AND GREG AND I AGREE ON
THIS.
IT IS A NO MORE FIST BLOB.
YOU CAN
LIE ON AN APPLICATION.
IT IS THE AMORPHOUS BLOB.
YOU CAN SEE I DON'T HAVE ANY
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
I'M NOT ANY OTHER -- ON
PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS.
THEY DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO DO A
CHECK ON YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
WILL WE EVER STOP PEOPLE WHO ARE
MENTALLY ILL FROM GETTING GUNS?
>> Shannon: THAT IS SOMETHING
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER TALKS ABOUT
IN 2012.
HE SAID IT WAS MUCH EASIER.
IF YOU FELT SOMEONE REALLY WAS A
DANGER TO THEMSELVES OR OTHER
PEOPLE, TICKET THEM INTO THE
FACILITY AND DO IT QUICKLY
WITHOUT A FULL-FLEDGED SHOOT
OCCASION.
SOME FACILITIES HAVE BEEN CLOSE.
THEY ARE NOT AVAILABLE.
HE SAID IT WAS MUCH DIFFERENT IN
THE '70s.
THE MAYOR TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THEY DESPERATELY WANTED
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES THEY
ARE IN UVALDE AND THEY DON'T
HAVE THEM.
THEY HAVE TO GO CITIES AWAY.
HE SAID THEY HAD DONATED
7.5 ACRES FOR A FACILITY TO BE
CONSTRUCTED.
THEY WERE EXCITED.
THEN THEY WERE TOLD THEY HAD TO
RAISE $26 MILLION.
HE SAID OUR POOR LITTLE
COMMUNITY DIDN'T HAVE IT SO THEY
HAD TO ABANDON THE PLANS FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: TOUGH STUFF.
WE ARE HEARING, JOEY, THERE WAS
A DIGITAL FOOTPRINT MORE THAN WE
THOUGHT.
HE WAS BUYING GUNS.
HE WAS IN CHAT ROOMS.
HE HAD INDICATED IN TEN MORE
DAYS SOMETHING WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THAT ALONG WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER CRUMBS THAT WE HEARD
ABOUT.
SELF INJURING.
HE HAD VIOLENT RHETORIC AT THE
JOB THAT HE HAD.
HE WAS BULLIED BECAUSE HE HAD A
LISP AND HE WORE EYELINER.
ALL OF THESE LITTLE CRUMBS BUT
NOTHING THAT REALLY AMOUNTS TO A
POINT WHERE POLICE CAN ACTUALLY
INTERVENE.
C7 THIS IS A FORM.
MULTIPLE PAGES.
THIS IS THE BACKGROUND CHECKS
CERTAIN PEOPLE WANT TO BE
UNIVERSAL.
YOU CAN FILL IT OUT AND THEY GET
SENT TO A GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
IT'S ONLY AS GOOD AS THE VETTING
OF THE GOVERNMENT AGENCY WHICH
IS ONLY AS GOOD AS THE REPORTING
OF THE LOCAL AGENCY.
SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS.
WEATHERBY COUNTY SHERIFFS, CITY
POLICE.
THAT FORM AND THAT PROCESS IS
ONLY AS GOOD AS THE JUDGE THAT
DECIDES WE'RE GOING TO DISMISS
THIS BECAUSE YOU'RE A MINER OR
THE D.A. THAT SAYS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO PROSECUTE THIS BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO RUIN YOUR LIFE AND
WE THINK YOU DESERVE A SECOND
CHANCE.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS NEED TO BE
ON BOARD.
WE CAN BROADEN THE GUN
TRANSACTIONS.
ADD BACKGROUND CHECKS BUT WE
STILL NEED TO FIX THE BACKGROUND
CHECK WHICH GOES ALL THE WAY TO
WHAT WAS TALKED ABOUT FOR
MONTHS.
SHOULD WE PROSECUTE CRIMINALS?
SHOULD WE WORRY ABOUT THEIR
RECORD IF THEY'VE DONE A VIOLENT
CRIME?
STUDIED THE NAVY YARD.
FOUR VIOLENT INCIDENTS, TO
INVOLVING A GUN.
NONE OF THEM MADE THEM TO THE
POINT WHERE IT WENT ON RECORD.
NOT ONLY GOT A GUN BUT GOT A
TOP-SECRET SECURITY CLEARANCE.
>> Judge Jeanine: FIVE PAGES.
BEFORE WE GO TO BREAK.
>> THIS IS WHY WE MAY NEED A
LONGER WAIT PERIOD AND PUT MORE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THIS TO
INVESTIGATE THESE THINGS AND GET
JUDGES LIKE YOU THE AUTHORITY
THE YOU DID NOT HAVE YEARS AGO.
>> I H